what did you uh what did you do during
the big blizzard max oh shoveled and
shoveled
right right oh yeah
you tell quite a story old man i'm too
tired to talk
that's a real corker save that for your
great-great-grandchildren what did you
do i shoveled and shoveled oh we're
gonna go now
[Laughter]
we'll see you later uh
it was amazing i don't know if you're
like the right i'm like i become a child
when you start snowing
that hard i mean obviously it creates
problems and
it ties up the transportation system and
not everybody loves it
i love it i start and i watch the news
and i'm one of those people
that they say we've got 20 inches but
they've got
25 inches over here and i get
competitive i'm like come on come on
let's get more let's get more
i just loved it i just wanted it to keep
snowing and snowing and snowing
and uh i think yesterday the final tally
was
20 20 inches in central park
i think uh jfk airport had like 25
inches
um staten island had over 50 feet of
snow
but i think they trucked it over there
for some reason they cheated
but anyway it was a big blizzard uh the
biggest blizzard anybody can remember
for a long time
and uh i was here at the office and i
was
looking out the window and i was
watching this whole thing happen
yesterday and i said
i gotta get out there i have to
experience this blizzard
and i have to take a camera crew with me
and just experience it
this was against the advice of my
physician
uh and all my loved ones are like don't
do it and i was and i said for my
viewers
i must and
and because let me tell you something
because those are nine people that
deserve the best
so so i took my camera crew and we went
out into the blizzard
and uh just uh experienced uh that that
incredible time take a look
they're calling it the worst blizzard in
50 years some say the worst blizzard in
100 years
one really old guy says it's the worst
blizzard in 400 years
but we think he's lying anyway it's
incredible take a look
[Music]
sir i'm going to speak to you hold on oh
hey how are you fine do you want me to
shovel and you can take a break
how come uh you have to use a shovel but
your friend gets to drive around that
little buggy
[Laughter]
okay as you can see they've made a giant
uh snow mountain right here
it's pretty amazing that's i'm not very
good at guessing but i think that's
that's about 60 feet high i think that's
probably about 900 tons of snow
and um what's your name sir come on and
step in here what's your name
uh james james where you from ohio okay
hey a lot of snow huh yeah
a lot that's usually where the
conversation ends
did you uh see that giant snowman i did
notice that yes we ever played king of
the hill
uh yes when i was younger basically one
person gets up at the top and the other
tries to throw them off you want to try
that right now for sure
oh look there's someone else up there
too that's great there's gonna be a
starbucks up there in about five minutes
well here we see probably the greatest
tragedy of today's blizzard a bicycle
completely encased in snow
that's some chinese food that will not
be delivered this evening for channel 4
news this is maurice duvoir
back to you stylist
[Applause]
[Music]
it was very homoerotic guys harder you
got to try harder
you're not put your back into it you're
sons of [ __ ]
everyone remain calm i have a shovel
everybody stay calm
someone go get
and i'll clear your path negan that's
for you and you walk that part all right
thank you
now i'm going to create a little
turnaround area in case you want to turn
around
and come back the other way
there you go oh that's nice very nice
that's nice
i did that for you is this the most snow
you've ever seen no i told you 1930.
i was born in 1922. it was uh
almost 15. the horses fell on the street
it was two stories high
what were the horses doing running
around on their own i wasn't running
around
they was doing uh work on the streets
and if a horse died
the sanitation worker carried a gun he
shot him in the head and they drew me to
each river wait if the horse died why do
you have to shoot him in the head
not even so a guy was walking around
shooting a leg he broke a leg man you're
not listening to me
you see a man who's clearly lost his
mind there's looking for him right now
at the sanitarium
you think he's being clever but he was
out here in july doing that he had a
little hat on there he goes look at him
prancing all the way this is not content
to know when i was when you were back
no i'm from boston awesome to fish steak
and i don't need bacon and i don't need
a lot of cans i don't need frozen
then it was in the news about the
undertakings they used to dig up
the expensive coffins and then take a
wing person
they dropped
[Applause]
[Music]
first quick quick quick hurry up one two
three
from heaven i love this spreader it's
the best treat
all right that was a lot of fun we'll
take a break when we come back you got
to stay tonight christopher walken is
here